[Music]
in life after death news what the [ __ ]
is going to tell me about these people
well apparently captain save-a-ho I like
him my scientists claims that you will
know when you die because your brain
keeps working
what kind of scientists I believe it I
think your brain keeps working and tell
your heart shut heart so your brain
tells you you died so he's like you'll
know when you die cuz your brain keeps
working so the brain is like hey bro
you're dead and then it's like oh you
got like a minute before you run out of
oxygen
oh god that's wrong then there's no good
way I don't want to know that I just
want to be dead I used to be so afraid
of debt that was like one of my biggest
fears but then like I heard something a
podcast once about how you have to think
of death as like before you were born -
you didn't know and you weren't
conscious and you had no like awareness
of it and that's what happens when you
die that's why you need reincarnation in
your life girl but what am I gonna
really coordinated as a [ __ ] buck cuz
I've been an [ __ ] well you get to
pick which one which life fulfills your
mission that universe I don't think
reincarnation has any to do with your
morals or anything like that it's just a
reset button what if I get brought back
it's like concrete you can learn enough
lessons but I'll support you are your
foundation for people the board I'd be
bored I don't think I could handle that
no you wouldn't you'd be looking upskirt
all day girl I was listening to a
podcast dude from this from this Navy
SEAL and he was saying
what'd he think so he was he was asked
how come Navy SEALs are down to dogs
crazy [ __ ] all the time I jump out of
planes and my face jumping on that and
he was saying he thinks the difference
is most people view death as the best
time to die is when you're old so it's
kind of like this brainwashed mentality
so people I gotta preserve myself and
telling all the time oh but he's saying
for a lot of the people that he met in
the SEAL Teams
the best time that died is you don't
know when that's gonna happen so there's
no extreme level of it has to be this
way preservation they just go hundred
percent all the time who gives a [ __ ]
yeah but the people who died first
you know they [ __ ] jump out and do
crazy [ __ ] we need those people though
they die
happy I guess and they die with
fulfilled lives instead of very long
boring lives I don't want to get old hmm
I think that I like once you get past
like being comfortable I'm kind of ready
to be a grandma though like I don't I
don't want to have like the motherhood
part I think what do you mean well I
just want my kids to have kids and I
could play with them and I don't have to
raise them
that sounds pretty fun like everyone has
to treat me with respect as I'm old and
you wouldn't have attachment to them
because like you're so your biggest your
biggest struggles are the things that
you like really hold on but on tire geo
of what how did you order the click what
I know that's a good point
oh yeah yeah I did it I created that
yeah you can watch together we both
cried it's not that I want to skip those
parts of my life it's just that I'm
tired and I feel like I don't have
energy and as being an old person you
have an excuse to be like I don't want
to you just agree J do I'm fatigued all
the times you have fiber IV let's do the
chronic fatigue syndrome I think I have
Candida oh you know what that is yeah
it's in your puss
yeah yeah and it can leak down to your
puss or up to your mouth or oral thrush
luckily it hasn't done either of those
two things but you can cause leaky gut
all kinds of [ __ ] and it makes you have
brain fog and fatigue and all this stuff
I feel like everything now causes brain
fog and fatigue there's that old implant
thing going around where it's like I'll
get your implants out because but you're
gonna forget you well I definitely don't
have implants and I definitely have
brain fog so I would just wish I could
blame it on age like I think more folks
are just like in tune with them their
brain health both more than now than
ever they're aware of it instead of
being like unaware place you know
blissful like ignorance or whatever like
people that were like I don't know in
Egyptian times are just like we just
have to build this [ __ ] wall win the
war and die yeah I'd be too tired to
build it I would be a terrible slave
like I'm so tired I'll be like just kill
me I don't care I don't think people
have the luxury of like feel
their feelings like that though yeah
they were just survival mode like our
parents didn't feel their feel but your
gut is connected to your brains Oh
totally everything comes from your gut
but they also a probiotic food yeah
they have healthier diaphragm like now
it's like we zapped a [ __ ] out of all of
our foods
yeah there's no bacteria I forgot we're
talking about death
oh this doctor his name is dr. Sam Parr
Nia he is studying consciousness after
death
and so he's been examining cardiac
arrest cases in Europe and in the u.s.
he's British by the way so he's saying
that the first the first phase of death
you might still experience some form of
consciousness because there's a lot of
people that have died like the cardiac
cardiac arrest people they've died and
they can they can describe accurately
what doctors and nurses were saying and
doing
Oh after they brought them back to life
yeah or I read about that on a reddit
thread there's a whole reddit thread of
people that went into comas and like
what did you or what do you remember
from your coma I can see that because
the Energy's still here so then even
this shuts off there's still battery
power here and it's still running on
that you know reading this article it
made me dream I mean it made me remember
about this dream that I had where I got
shot and I was like laying there on the
ground and I was just thinking of like
Isaac and I'm like oh my god he's gonna
be an orphan now I know like I mean it's
dead but in my mind I was just oh my god
the one that really matters is gonna dog
was a good mom and I woke up and I was
crying Oh like just saying that dream
though I was dead but I was still
conscious but you could die in it and
then you know that you were a good mom
so don't worry about your body also
pumps what's called DMT when you're
dying is that when you get it yeah yeah
druggies are like no I
I'm spirit world she ever tried it no I
well I tried it but I don't think it was
like real I've heard stories it sounds
right nothing I was I was like hi and
pretty [ __ ] up but like I what I
didn't do any of the like alternate
universe ship but like that's a natural
chemical in your body that your brain
produces right before you die and it
pumps it and that's why people say they
they see their life flash before their
eyes yeah when you take the interior
life flash before your eyes like you see
your whole life span all within like 15
minutes and then and you see all your
life plays into the whole universe and
all of I gotta do it every no you go and
do that Chile but you're just gonna bomb
it a lot CMT you don't have to vomit and
you don't have to have a spelling mom
maybe I'll make you better mom I'm not
gonna do I don't know but it's a
naturally produce count upon your body
still a drug huh it kills your ego yeah
every every defense mechanism that you
have you know what I think that is it's
like when you're dying it's just you're
you're it's brain is uploading into the
cloud yeah so then it resets and then
you go back it's a would y'all ever like
freeze your brains like Walt Disney did
no legend I think it's true I would want
to come back with something new like why
are you for it I don't want to come back
at the same person do you have your
memories is that what deja vu isn't [ __ ]
I don't I don't know it's a glitch in
the system but I remember reading about
how when people get guillotine their
brains their brain still worked they
could see their their studies like
people that get were they talking like I
can't stop me
it took them a while for them to shut
down like they were so that's just
nerves squash a bug and it's still like
like rigor mortis yeah but that's just
the nursing I got told that when I was a
kid and I just [ __ ] freaked me out
I'd have nightmares about what if I like
movies that people get spliced in half
and they're just like yeah another body
full of body pulls a bird yeah oh [ __ ]
look at this real dude dead [ __ ]
scares me like this why I think the
thought of it like like we're having
this now and then tomorrow that's all
gone and then like in terms of you in
the universe like on this planet like
your loved ones if you were gone what if
no waves a realization that one day I'm
gonna die and I [ __ ] panic I'm like
yeah I can't think about I can't think
about [ __ ] like that I don't want to
think about like a conspiracy theories
cuz i [ __ ] with me so hard I hope that
like something for like my sake I hope
some [ __ ] happens when you die like I
hope like big gates open it's like PI -
[ __ ] you guys this is like tier 1 all
I'd like reunite with all the people
that pass yeah and like not like heaven
though cuz I think having sounds a
little like that's what I'm say
reincarnation but you come back to this
shitty play you don't have to do there's
there's theories there's other planet
you know there's theories it like is it
like the Disney ride Indiana Jones and
then you get two different adventures
yeah beanie and a Jones right you don't
like every day every time you go on it
you don't go to the same thing open it
you go through different adventures
really no you go to use to be that way
oh we change think you just go to the
same one now no it's it used to be you
went to three different doors now it's
just the same oh sorry to kill the mood
we love that one of the endings I don't
remember like one had arrows and one had
a boulder and one had this but now they
just combined all of it oh that sounds
so fun because back in the day that was
like the most popular Riley like had
like long ass lines for it would they
combine them I don't know
I'm not Disney that's like what [ __ ]
right now is like my goal is to try to
unlock a lot of things I think that's
the point of life of your consciousness
yeah unlock different compartments why
do I react a certain way build new habit
are you gonna take DMT maybe if I'm
ready for it you like psychedelics I did
a lot of acid in drugs but then that's
why I'm afraid of doing drugs now
because I abused it so then not if I
take it I'll be like that's cuz you're
you're actually it's in the zodiac
you're the baby you're gonna come back a
lot because you're just you just you're
new yeah I actually got a brain scan
done this week to like look into my
anxiety we all want to see the picture
yeah it's a brain scan activity so you
can see I was like curious about drug
use and like I've been controlling my
anxiety well see if like your amygdalas
after that's like a regular healthy
brain it's like the blue is regular
thinking red is like you're actively
thinking you never want white why it is
like that what does I mean that's my
brain Oh too much thinking so that's
where my anxiety comes from mine's
probably nothing you can like action
you've got a bunch of dicks on your mind
but like you can go to parts of your
brain and be like oh that's where trauma
looks like I did a video Bobby how did
you stimulate your anxiety give you an
injection and then they they make you do
a bunch of tests so like that's why I'm
curious why how they're studying the
brain in what kind of see what if that
makes me happy like they gave me some in
anxiety [ __ ] and I start doing tests and
[ __ ] and you're like in limitless and
you should be did you watch free solo oh
my god a movie the free shots of the
climber the guy that climbed the El
Capitan a Yosemite without a cord they
scan his brain in the night this is the
normal anxiety center for a person it
was like this much activity when they
scanned his it was like this like nine
so like yeah nothing scares him in the
world but they also said that he was
like on the spectrum right
wouldn't that be not helpful for
survival it's not yeah that's why he
does the [ __ ] free solo but that's
also why he's able to push things to the
limits you know I think everyone like
Steve Jobs we meet that for humans
because they are the ones that's gonna
try the mushroom to see if it's edible
yeah and if crazy Larry [ __ ] eats
that mushroom
survives we know thank you crazy Larry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]